Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Abbiamo fondato un'azienda
nel settore peggiore che ci sia.
Siamo Bianca e Livia, abbiamo 24 anni,
e abbiamo deciso di fondare un'azienda
nel settore dell'editoria
e dell'informazione.
Un settore che è in crisi da anni;
un settore in declino,
che ha perso completamente
la fiducia dei lettori;
un settore che è ignorato
dalle nuove generazioni
e criticato dalle generazioni precedenti.
A questo punto, giustamente direte:
ma che l'avete aperta a fare, un'azienda?
Abbiamo aperto un'azienda
in questo settore
un po' perché siamo masochiste,
e un po' perché crediamo
che se qualcosa è in profonda crisi,
qualcosa che serve alla società,
non possiamo semplicemente
guardarlo andare a fondo.
Ma per raccontarvi come mai abbiamo deciso
di rivoluzionare questo settore,
dobbiamo fare un salto indietro nel tempo,
e capire cosa è andato storto
nel mondo dei giornali tradizionali.
E come mai oggi molte persone,
quando ne parlano,
tendono a storcere il naso.
Dobbiamo tornare alla metà degli anni '90,
al boom di Internet, e all'inizio
dell'era delle reti digitali.
In questo momento, all'improvviso,
le testate si trovano davanti
nuovi canali e nuove dinamiche
che minacciano i giornali,
ma soprattutto la carta stampata.
Aumentano gli investimenti sul web,
e così aumentano anche le aziende
che iniziano a utilizzare Internet
per farsi pubblicità.
Ed è qui che viene compiuto
un grande passo falso.
Le testate entrano in una nuova realtà,
con delle logiche che appartengono
a un mondo che ormai è vecchio.
Iniziano a produrre una grandissima
quantità di contenuti,
in maniera completamente gratuita.
Mentre prima erano i lettori
a pagare il giornale stampato,
e quindi a pagare
per quello che leggevano,
adesso a pagare sono le aziende.
È il nuovo modello di business,
che è basato sulla vendita
di banner pubblicitari.
Perché questo funzioni, però,
c'è bisogno di attrarre
un gran numero di lettori
sui nostri articoli,
e che questi lettori facciano
un grande numero di click.
Così ha origine il clickbait,
o gli articoli spazzatura,
quegli articoli strutturati in modo tale
da avere titoli sensazionalistici,
anche a fronte di notizie
inesistenti o irrilevanti.
Quegli articoli, che sicuramente
avrete visto un sacco di volte,
che dal titolo sembra scoppiata
la Terza Guerra Mondiale,
poi aprendoli ci accorgiamo
che parlano di una litigata
al bar sotto casa.
Ma se scrivi degli articoli
soltanto per attrarre click,
dopo un po' i tuoi lettori
se ne accorgeranno,
capiranno che la qualità è calata,
e inizieranno a fidarsi meno di te.
Questo perché tu, editore digitale,
hai messo in secondo piano
quello che dovrebbe essere
il vero obiettivo dell'informazione,
cioè aiutare le persone
a conoscere meglio
il mondo che le circonda,
in modo tale da farsi
un'opinione a riguardo.
Ma non è finita qui,
perché dopo l'arrivo di Internet
sono arrivati anche i social network,
che hanno complicato
ulteriormente le cose.
Oggi, per fare informazione
non basta avere un sito web
su cui attrarre i lettori,
ma bisogna portare i propri contenuti
lì dove le persone stanno,
cioè sui social.
Ed è qui che entriamo in gioco noi.
Come dicevo, siamo Bianca e Livia,
abbiamo 24 anni,
e quello che facciamo
è informazione sui social network.
Di solito, quando diciamo le parole
"informazione" e "social network" vicine,
le persone iniziano un po'
a storcere il naso.
Ma perché facciamo
informazione sui social?
Facciamo informazione sui social perché,
in mezzo a tutto questo marasma
che vi abbiamo raccontato,
è proprio sui social
che si sono raggruppate
le persone che sono state completamente
dimenticate dai media tradizionali,
le nuove generazioni.
Qui, le persone di solito dicono:
"I giovani non si informano";
"I giovani non leggono";
"I giovani sono svogliati".
Posso dirvi, possiamo dirvi
che questo non è vero:
i giovani sono assetati di informazione.
Il problema, questa volta, è che nessuno
si è mai preoccupato di raggiungerli.
Oggi, quando un ragazzo
si sveglia la mattina,
non va in edicola a comprare il giornale,
e non si informa neanche sul sito web
di qualche quotidiano online.
Oggi, quando un ragazzo
si sveglia la mattina,
prende in mano il telefono
e apre i social.
Inizia a scorrere contenuti
alla ricerca di qualcosa di interessante,
ma qui non trova le testate tradizionali,
perché queste non si sono
mai interessate ai social network,
e non ne hanno capito il potenziale.
Di conseguenza, oggi non sanno
come comunicare con i giovani,
che paradossalmente
sono proprio la generazione
che avrebbe maggiore bisogno
di informazioni di qualità,
perché sono quella generazione
che cambierà il mondo in cui viviamo.
Si tratta di una generazione fondamentale,
ma che fondamentalmente
è stata abbandonata.
Quindi, a questo punto,
come facciamo a riprendercele
queste nuove generazioni, questi giovani?
Non è facile.
Prima di tutto, quello che dobbiamo fare
è dimenticarci completamente
tutto quello che sapevamo
sui metodi di fruizione dell'informazione.
Mentre un tempo esistevano i lettori,
adesso questo concetto non esiste più.
Adesso esistono gli utenti, gli user:
persone che usano i contenuti,
interagiscono con essi in maniera attiva.
L'informazione, che un tempo
era unidirezionale,
ora non lo è assolutamente più.
Ora, tra i news maker e gli utenti,
c'è un rapporto profondo,
c'è una relazione di fiducia
e di contatto continuo.
Dopodiché, dobbiamo fare
un altro piccolo sforzo,
che è quello di pensare
di essere dei pesci rossi.
Siamo, mediamente,
più intelligenti dei pesci rossi:
però, quando siamo sui social,
i pesci rossi ci battono.
I pesci rossi hanno
una soglia dell'attenzione
maggiore della nostra,
che è di otto secondi.
Otto secondi in cui,
se sei un newsmaker, e fai informazione,
devi convincere un utente
che stai raccontando
qualcosa di interessante,
che vale la pena che spenda ancora un po'
di quella sua preziosa attenzione
a leggere quello che gli stai raccontando.
Tutto questo mettendo da parte
la notifica dell'amica su WhatsApp,
le foto dei compagni sui social,
e la canzone che voleva
ascoltare su Spotify.
Insomma, è una lotta assurda
per prendere il bene più difficile
da raggiungere dei nostri tempi:
l'attenzione.
È una lotta che possiamo
riuscire a vincere
solamente se riusciamo a entrare
nella mente dei nostri utenti.
Oggi, per essere efficaci sui social,
bisogna creare contenuti accattivanti,
che siano in grado di convincere l'utente
a fermarsi e a dedicarci
un po' della sua attenzione.
Ma cosa significa questo?
Bisogna creare dei contenuti
che abbiano una grafica d'impatto,
che siano in grado
di trasmettere freschezza,
ma che allo stesso tempo
siano anche in grado di parlare
di temi sensibili, e rilevanti,
con le parole giuste.
Ad esempio, come faccio
a convincere un ventenne
che è importante sapere come funzionano
le pensioni nel nostro paese?
Noi lo facciamo così.
E come faccio a convincere un giovane
a spiegarmi quali sono i temi
veramente rilevanti
per le nuove generazioni?
Essendo disposto ad ascoltarli,
e  capendo ad esempio che per loro
è sempre più importante
parlare di salute mentale:
un tema che i media tradizionali
trascurano fin troppo,
ma per le nuove generazioni,
soprattutto dopo la pandemia,
è diventato centrale.
E infine, bisogna trovare il modo
per dare alle persone gli spunti giusti
per sviluppare uno sguardo critico
rispetto al mondo che li circonda,
e magari mettere un po' in discussione
lo status quo a cui siamo abituati.
E tutto questo bisogna farlo
mantenendo sempre una grande coerenza
con i propri valori
e il proprio tono di voce.
Perché è su questi due elementi
che si basa il rapporto di fiducia,
ciò che è in grado di trasformare
degli utenti qualsiasi
in una vera e propria community.
Insomma,
fare informazione sui social
e farla per le nuove generazioni,
è un casino.
Potevamo fare altro:
però, se torniamo alla nostra
macchina del tempo di prima,
ci accorgiamo
che non accettare questa sfida
sarebbe il secondo grande errore
che il mondo dell'informazione
potrebbe commettere.
Abbiamo deciso di aprire un'azienda
nel settore più difficile che ci sia,
nel settore peggiore che ci sia,
perché crediamo che qualcuno,
a queste nuove generazioni,
debba pur pensare.
E che non possiamo ignorarle
solamente per paura di affrontare
la difficoltà del mondo in cui vivono.
Fare informazione significa
sforzarsi, tutti i giorni,
di abilitare le persone
a conoscere un po' meglio
il mondo intorno a loro,
nel bene e nel male;
e anche dare loro gli strumenti
per capire come cambiare le cose,
come avere un impatto.
Se non si fa questo lavoro
con le nuove generazioni,
a cosa serve fare informazione?
Fare informazione è la responsabilità
più grande che ci sia.
È il settore peggiore dei nostri tempi,
ma anche il più importante
della nostra epoca,
ed è per questo che l'abbiamo scelto.
(Applausi)